brian you're on your fifth feature film
now so
are you feeling more hopeful about
filmmaking
2014 than you did 15 years ago
um in my own career yeah i feel great i
feel extremely hopeful
um and i it's because i'm i'm growing as
a human being and growing as a filmmaker
and
i'm hopeful just in life in general so
yeah i'm extremely excited about it and
yes absolutely do you see though that
it's more of a job now
so going back to the i wish it was a
full-time job
geez i wish i wish yeah
i mean i wish i would get you know uh
would make enough money on these films
to
make a decent living but you know i have
to just keep doing what i'm
keep practicing it and and one day you
know it'll be
that's true that's tough question i mean
it's not just work it's it's
it's livelihood it's um
you know it's an opportunity everything
is an opportunity every day every time i
meet someone who could
i could potentially work with that's an
opportunity whether it's an
actor or a or a crew person whether it's
like i'm looking for a great art
director right now and that's an
opportunity for me to develop a
relationship that could go on for
another 10 years
so every person i come in contact with
is just another
you know opportunity to enrich my life
and their life so that's how i look at
it
so since you said it's not quite a job
because it's not a constant paycheck
again going back to what motivates you
it's just you have to get these stories
out of you it sounds like it's just what
i do i mean it's i i've
been fortunate that you know i've been
wanting to do this for a long time and
you know this is how my this is what
i've
what i've the bet i've made for myself
you know i'm i'm an independent
filmmaker i'm going to have good years
i'm going to have bad years and
you know as i work my way up i hope to
keep climbing up this
big hill and i hope that i don't reach a
point where i'm just climbing parallel
you know i want to keep
fighting a good fight fighting a good
battle to get to where
um you know to be heard and to reach a
wide audience and to affect people
and
so i like that so you said this is what
you've chosen for yourself
did you know that from the beginning
that it was a choice
yeah i mean i i didn't think it was
going to be like you know you never
think it's going to turn out like this
you know i mean i'm very
happy and fortunate i've been able to to
to make these films
um i didn't know it's going to be this
hard that's for sure
not at all at what point did you say to
yourself
this is a choice i'm gonna keep going
with it i'm not gonna
give up and say they wouldn't let me in
i'm still gonna make movies um i would
say when i was going trying to when i
was applying
like right as i got into film school and
i applied to a lot of big film schools i
didn't i didn't get into a lot of them
because my standardized testing
wasn't as high as like you know what
they should have been to get into a big
school
so i think when my first year film
school i had a professor
who was just so negative and like such a
bad gave bad vibes in the classroom i
was like you can't do this and i told
him i
my idea for my project and he goes
you'll never
pull that off john he goes you'll never
this idea you have in your head
and your 17 year old head you won't pull
that off
and i never forgot that because i wanted
to shoot in a hotel and i had like i
wanted to do all these things
and i proved them wrong i did it and at
the very end when when i whenever
he never apologized for treating me like
that but my last meeting
when the class was over you had like a
review i guess he said well john you did
it you pulled it off and that's all i
said
you know i'd never forget it's one of
those things you never forget
um so and plus if
if other people can do it i mean they're
shooting a tv show in this hotel right
now
those people working on that show that
director and those producers they're no
smarter or more talented than the
majority of people
out here fighting me and all the people
watching this
interview or watching all the other
interviews it's just
you know they got the opportunity to do
that that director knew the right person
he got the opportunity to go direct that
tv show
you know the cards fell in the place he
had more resources
that's fine you know just
so what would you have said to 17 year
old
brian john back then if you were that
professor
what would you have said to him like oh
this is going to be a hard scene
you can try it i don't know i mean what
would you oh
like well i would say do you have i
would probably say do you have
permission to shoot here
he didn't even like do you have a permit
like how are you you know do you have
permission have you talked to them
what are you gonna do if someone gets
hurt i would just ask all the practical
things that you would ask
um you know are you gonna would you if
you're shooting
up in alton because i was going to
school in carbondale are you going to
use
crew from the film school if you are how
are they all getting up there
or are you gonna use crew you know i
would ask more practical questions he
just said
i can't couldn't do it instead of trying
to figure out how i was gonna do it
and be constructive about it he just
said i couldn't do it
which is like the worst thing a teacher
could say to a student
you know and i remember his name too
because you don't
um i remember this guy's name because
you know you forget all this teacher's
name but i remember this guy's name
i don't want to say it but and i'm
almost
thankful i'm almost thankful he did that
because you know
that's i didn't forget it you know
you